hi i'm marlon clark and i'm a huge  supporter of the global teacher prize  because it shines a light on the great  work that teachers do  all over the world now more than ever we  must shine that light  on the work that teachers are doing as  we start this new decade the world is  facing some of its greatest challenges  climate change conflict and of course  global pandemics  all will require teachers to pass on  baton of education to the next  generation  now personally i'd like to tell you  about a teacher that made a huge  difference to  my life dr richard mansfield he taught  me english at college  he got me reading more than i've ever  read before and also  he got me to see the world in a  completely different way and with humor  most importantly he got me to think for  myself so from me  thank you dr richard mansfield